well
you see there is a there is a sort of a
misconception that that that pace and
speaking quickly is the same thing you
can have pace by people not speaking
quickly it depends on the cut
it depends on on the rhythm of the thing
well structure to me is
compare it with building a house
you have to have a base where the house
is going to stand you have to have walls
you have to have
uh
pillars that are going to hold it up
staircase the second story and whatever
it is it is a kind of a mixer writing a
movie is a mixture of of architecture
and
forgive me the pump is worth poetry so
most of the time it is kind of off the
kind of the script is there
and if something better occurs you know
i'm the first one to accept it if it
comes from an actor if it comes from
if it comes
from
an electrician from the script girl
even if it comes from a producer which
is rare enough
well
you see there is a there is a sort of a
misconception that that that pace and
speaking quickly is the same thing you
can have pace by people not speaking
quickly it depends on the cut it depends
on on the rhythm of the thing
because uh
leisurely moments silent moments uh
they they have much more power but
certain pictures have to be played at a
just
rattling things off you know don't don't
confuse that you know there's obviously
a confusion in in in our world that's
like people confuse
poverty with misery
i have known very many poor people they
have not been miserable and i can tell
you people in true stale that are really
miserable you know
this confusion kind of constantly occurs
billy how would you determine structure
well structure to me is
compare it with building a house
you have to have a base where the house
is going to stand you have to have walls
you have to have
pillars that are going to hold it up
staircase the second story or whatever
it is it is a kind of a mixer writing a
movie is a mixture of of architecture
and
forgive me the pump is worth poetry
or storytelling
on a certain level but it has to have
it has to have
a
very solid
uh
thing so that the the the second act
follows the first act on it's strong
enough to
keep the audience in the seats to see
the third act what is happening there
but you you need that very very very
strongly it's not that i make myself a
drawing and a blueprint and
it's just it's just kind of an
instinctive thing i'm talking about
myself because you've talked to another
500 writers everybody has got his own
method some just start writing you know
kind of some some have the the
the the kind of uh
the kind of flighty mind of of
of uh
we have a very good example now forrest
gump you know the writers who who
function like forrest gump you don't
know where it's going but
you can't do that with a picture i mean
i couldn't do it with a picture well how
do you do it i tell you i i mine is kind
of another unique thing that i i cannot
i don't like it if you write a scene
and we say we'll fix that later we will
manicure it
and go to the next scene to the next
scene i just go back to the first scene
and
until it is about as good as possible i
may change something subsequently but i
never write first version second version
third version
last weekend
i wanted to catch the atmosphere of new
york i needed
i needed third avenue at that time there
was still an elevator going up above i
needed that
it needed
vast vistas of
of new york of skyscrapers of
when he's going up third avenue
uh you know trying to hack to
to pawn the typewriter because he needs
money for some more booze
personally
just between you and me you know i i
much rather
shoot inside the studio because i can
control it
i don't have to fight the light which is
going all the time the weather the sun
is going all the time
oh it starts raining and then
you re-shoot for the and then
the sun comes out again you know you
have no control and you compromise
i'm embarrassed to tell you the truth
and so many actors about shooting in
front of a lot of people i'll tell you a
good story about it just
care for another drink
okay now this is what happened we were
shooting seven year itch with marilyn
monroe
and you remember that famous shot
do you remember the wind that is lifting
her skirt well we were all set up to
shoot that thing you know on the 59th
and madison something like it
i had in order to make sure that this
skirt is being lifted not only that they
were five and ultimately ten thousand
people they were like
they were
the electricians and the and the
mechanics who were working the
the fan down below so that it would work
right
they accepted big bribes of people
around they all wanted to be underneath
there and look up marilyn's
skirt and uh
and we did it and we did it and did it
and it never quite worked and people
were heckling from the sidelines you
know
and people were running up for
autographs and it was very embarrassing
i tell you and the judy major who was at
that time the the husband of
of maryland
you know he he was watching it and he
didn't like it very much
his wife making a spectacle of herself
and i i didn't i didn't like the lack of
control i couldn't really get it right
and finally ultimately i i
we did that shot in the studio it was
perfect how do you go about developing
your characters i tell you uh
i i learned that i learned that from
from charles lawton
we were doing a picture called uh
witness for the prosecution and
the first two days he was rather shaky
and
then the third day he would come to me
says i got it let's do the first two
days again which i very often do because
you don't know the crew you don't know
how it's going to sound it's just kind
of more or less you should have tested
he he searches in his memory for a
character
that he had known
and
and
he then placed that character he knew he
knew he was searching for
a judge or a lawyer that he knew it that
was it was in the legal profession
and and and once he he he gets the the
sound of that guy
and the manner of of of uh
walking
of looking
he's got it but that goes with every
picture he just tries to fix on a on on
somebody that knows and he uses it he
elaborates on it naturally but he uses
it to be in the right key as you would
say
on the screen
you cannot take a character of
of one of your one of your uh
uh
friends or people that you
know but uh
and and make him into a murderer you
have to plant that thing
uh
that thing within that
character it was it was not it was not
very easy with uh with uh uh
fred mcmurray in in in
in double indemnity to make him into
into a uh into a murderer but uh
you had to believe it you had to believe
it and you had to have i was trying very
hard
a certain amount of pity that this that
this guy was
was led into something which which i
which had
i saw it with my own eyes how he felt
and i was worried about him
and he did it and i understand why he
did it but i will because i object to it
you have to you have to plant things you
have a character but you have to plant
string streaks in his character moments
seconds
uh
where he makes a decision
and you say that that goes with that guy
you know this is what else did i expect
it's no surprise it gets to be logical
to the
is
yes well that's that's that's if if i
could explain it you know this is like
like
you know if if i if i knew the formula
you know i would patent it but
nobody quite knows uh how to arrive at
it but
the best illustration
which i use when people ask me about the
deluge dots now if you have a class of
students
writers let us say or directors and you
say
i would like you to dramatize
the the following situation there is a
king and there's a queen
there is a
lieutenant the king is played by george
barbier
a very opulent fat actor
in his 60s the queen is yunna merkel she
was very pretty them
and the adjutant the guidance of the
king is maurice chevalier
now dramatize the situation that the
queen has an affair with the lieutenant
and the king finds out
now do it do it your way do it any way
you want to and those hundred students
who are very good to comedy very good
they're very imaginative they go out and
they come back a week later
and they will all have
good solutions
amusing maybe long maybe uh
maybe they're a little too explicit
maybe it's too sensible but nobody
nobody in the world could have come up
with a better solution than mr lubitz
does here's his solution
and i'm putting now the opening scene in
the smiling lieutenant
you open up in the bedroom of the king
bobby
and the queen and
he's getting dressed and there's little
nose rubbing and tickling and saying
it's all very sweet and she's very nice
to the king
now he leaves the bedroom
leaves the bedroom
and as he leaves the the bedroom we see
that at the door
with a sword standing there and clicking
his heels is
mauricio valley
and he's now watching the king and the
king is going down
some steps it's a long staircase that
leads down from the bedroom of in that
palace boom boom boom boom
now we cut back to mr shirali and he
sees that the king is leaving
and he now enters the bedroom of the
queen
the door is closed
you don't cut into the bed
now
as the king is descending
he suddenly sees that he
he forgot the belt and the sword
he turns around and he goes up the steps
back into the bedroom now we have a
situation going ah
now he opens the door
goes in the door closes we are still
outside we're never inside
now the king comes out and he's got the
belt and he's got with the sword right
and he is smiling and now he's going
down the step boom boom boom and
suddenly he tries to put it on and it's
not his belt it's much too small for him
[Laughter]
now back he goes again and now he finds
him under the bed right
but you see you see how he operates that
thing you know it's it's all done with a
kind of a a akote kind of a kind of uh
throwing it away
so that is that is the the little bit
statue
how do you write an original something
like the apartment you told us you got
the inspiration for that from a picture
david lena directed it was called a
brief encounter one of his best pictures
black and white very simple married
woman a lover who lives in london and
she would come and see him and he would
use
he would use a friend's apartment
for for for his tris or whatever you
want to call it
and i remember we were shooting we were
shooting
strong like it had and we were halfway
through and i was in love with lemon and
i just thought there's an enormous
talent i did not know him before
and i if i could get him for a next
picture but what what kind of a next
picture can we can we can we can we find
and um i i i have um
draws full of of
first acts of characters of
curtains of
themes for future pictures and i
remember that i had something there that
that fitted him and i found it that it
was a five
page outline
uh for the apartment namely the story of
the friend whose apartment the leading
man was using it and the lion just very
simply started with
but what about the man
who has to crawl back into his warm bed
what happens to him
and i decided that that would be a good
uh a good uh
uh
character to to to start with uh
and lemon was just he was just
not really a leading man in the sense
you know of richard bartleman off clark
gable there was there was he was a
leading man but there was something
funny and pathetic at the same time you
you touched on a very good point because
i think i i should i should and i will
henceforth if i get another crack at it
i should prepare myself better but uh
unfortunately the way the industry works
the actor is just flying in from
yugoslavia
and uh
and he arrives on friday on monday we
have to start shooting
and
we don't we don't have the time you have
when you're working on the play to
really rehearse and rehearse and find
so most of the time it is kind of off
the kind of the script is there
and if something better occurs you know
i'm the first one to accept it if it
comes from an actor if it comes from
if it comes
from
an electrician from the script
girl even if it comes from a producer
which is rare enough
but
i should have i should have more time
and very very good and very professional
director
like
herbert ross he uh i just saw his last
picture last night and i talked to
matthau and he said you know we had two
weeks rehearsals that's very very
helpful but
it uh it it is not it is not
it is a luxury that you cannot always
afford but i will insist on it it's it's
it's terribly important
that you that because while you're
rehearsing that doesn't cost any money
once you start shooting it's 25 35 50
000 a day that the time is the time is
before and not after
after you know you start after the war
started after you're over the top you've
got to go you wanted to go into
directing because you you feel your
scripts we are not we are betrayed or
you're not you need to control
i wanted to have more control and uh
you know i just thought that directing
was already fun
writing is misery writing is sweat
writing is hard labor
the fun is to be on the set if you have
a good script and
and capable
or
if you're lucky enough to have
outstanding actors that's a real fun you
know that's that's the the thing to do
you mean the writing is the toughest
part of the filmmaking so you it's it's
too much to to do the toughest part and
somebody else's absolutely yeah the
holiday it's like making the bed for
somebody and then then he hops into the
bed you know and i go home you know
but you were not really satisfied with
the system because you wanted to achieve
more control you switch from
scriptwriter to director and then
director to producer producer director
and that is the level of the producer
who
uh
talking about great producers like the
thawbergs and selznicks and
and the the gold ones
um
i'm talking about
a studio producer who
you know since they cannot uh write
since they cannot direct since they
cannot act since they cannot compose
they become the the head of everything
and that was the ultimate control so it
was a question of
not of power
but of of ultimately having it as close
to
on the screen to what you what you first
imagined
to have it as close to that after the
execution
you